[Music]
[Applause]
thank you this is the best day of my
life
i swear to god but then you bring in
satan into this into the the branding
and all that you were a skateboarder in
the 90s
uh skated with uh they call him the
birdman is it
tony hawk uh hey what's up i'm tony hawk
and today
eddie how's it going brother good
alhamdulillah so we were talking a
little bit about the the glasses
yes yes so tell us uh fill us in
on why you prefer to wear the glasses
uh to be quite honest i'm a uh i'm a
technical guy by trade
um went to computer science in 2002
uh however prior to that my life in
skateboarding was sort of an
anonymous type of lifestyle it was
better to be anonymous at that point
yeah skateboarding in the you know late
80s
early 90s was sort of a uh sort of
rebellious activity and it was
sort of like punk rock i guess that type
of genre
of lifestyle so people looked uh upon us
a little strangely
um so at those those points we had a lot
of run-ins with security guards and
things so it became
habitual to sort of not reveal your name
in a certain way but nowadays we all
know
with these new netflix things exposing
what's happening on uh
with social media taking all your data
it's sort of just a privacy thing it's
sort of just a preference
um not hiding myself from other people i
would i wouldn't want to do that but i
mean
uh you know your image is getting
scanned and things like that it's uh
you know we're all we're all sort of i
like what you said i mean keeping your
family safe
not putting in this day and age people
are just you know
putting everything online but you also
avoid uh having your children and your
family online i mean
you have a lot of even celebrities who
are
up to that they they don't allow their
kids uh
and the family a lot do but you have
also you know many that don't
so you prefer and that's i think safer
route i mean protect people it is i mean
i'm not i'm not i'm not trying to fall
into the trap of doing selfies all the
time and becoming so
some vain glory person right which is
again
i'm a type of guy as a skateboarder like
i said growing up we were sort of
anti-mainstream
at that point so this sort of mindset is
still in my head where i see a lot of
people
playing on the phones playing on the
tablets and playing playing playing
entertaining themselves and
staring at other people's lives you know
what i mean it becomes it's
sometimes we have to use the computer as
a tool and not a toy
right it's not always a play toy um
and to make that distinction i think is
is clear there has to be a point where
you know
taking selfies of yourself you have to
reflect on that in a way
where yeah um it's not very
productive in a way right so did the
deen play any part of that because you
do have obviously in the dean you have
the evil eye you have hassa
you have these things did that concern
you at the same time
it did actually from my early days in
islam here so ten years ago i was
hearing you know some brothers they were
mentioning uh during
during ramadan during eid some brothers
don't like the picture taken so be
careful of that and uh
i heard a couple lectures as well about
people discussing you know the pros and
cons of taking pictures of yourself and
whether prophet muhammad peace be upon
him would would
would engage in this type of behavior
right now
some people keep it for for remembrance
or memoirs and some people are doing it
really just for the likes and
the uh the fan base so to speak right
there's no real purpose other than they
want
gratification in a way right they're
lusting after that
that uh that like or that comment or
something right and
i i don't follow that trend i don't i
don't need that type of uh
admiration right so it's a good reminder
for all of us
yeah and tell us so you were you were
skating with the likes uh
you were a skateboarder in the 90s uh
skated with uh
they call them the birdman is it tony
hawk
tony hawk the birdman yeah he used to do
demos uh
all around before he was really famous
for his video games and his uh
you know the 900 and all the things he's
done he has done quite a bit for
skateboarding obviously as an ambassador
uh but he's just a regular guy back in
the 90s he wasn't famous where we would
attack him it was a
a roller rink in uh you know in the
toronto area where he would do
demonstrations and we went there and
yeah we met tony hawk face to face and a
bunch of other uh big names back then
yeah it was a tight-knit circle back
there so
what at what age did you start
skateboarding i started skateboarding in
uh
at the age of 12 i believe was my first
board
first professional board though was uh i
think 14 or 15.
so it's been quite a run right the kids
at the skate park still ask me today
it's uh have that younger look so
how long have you been skating and i you
know i'm saying you know 30 years bro
so is he like is tony hawk for those
that don't know is he like the michael
jordan lebron james of skateboarding
exactly he's the you know when you say
skateboarding
extreme sports he's the spokesman
nowadays for skateboarding right so
i think everybody who's 40 and under
knows who tony hawk is for sure um
the video game is one of the most
worldwide selling video games he just
re-released another one
and uh he's always in the limelight for
something right yeah
i i want you to uh you shared something
with us and i want you to take us
through this we're gonna go through this
video together
yeah we're gonna help you educate us a
little bit on this and there's one part
of it
that actually caught my attention never
before in history competition will be
seen at 900
900 900.
you guys want to see the 900 what's this
900
they're all everybody's all excited and
you just you also said it the 900.
the 900 is uh it's it's it's in terms of
the degrees of the spin so a 360 is a
one circle a 720 is two circles and a
900 is two and a half circles
so he did two and a half rotations in
the air
and uh before that you know the 720
was the uh was the big move and the 900
had never been done
and that was the first time the 900 had
been done so it was a huge thing
so that was like spinning three times
two two and a half times two and a half
since since uh a few years ago they've
they've progressed and they've
they've done the three rotations so the
900 is two and a half rotations on the
skateboard in the air
someone's gotten three so he did two and
a half someone's gotten to three
someone's gotten to three and there's a
13 year old who did three and a half i
think so he did like a 1440 it's called
right so it's it's it's going it's
progressing rapidly at this point where
kids are
are playing the video games and they
have that sort of edge that they can
visualize yeah the the trick and as a
martial artist yourself i i know we do a
lot of thinking
and preparation prior to um
you know entering a match or entering a
contest we're visualizing what we're
gonna do
based on uh the opponent and his uh the
tape or something that we watch right so
yeah let's keep going through this honey
was either gonna
make it or kill himself trying 900 with
him so this is tony hawk this is him
buying it so many
times this seems to be him quite quite a
few years ago but
actually this was x games i believe 2001
is when he when he made this happen
right when he
actually landed it rolled away um
yeah so i think he had some time
obviously i think he was practicing it
behind the scenes before this
competition however uh obviously
it's it's it's hit or miss it's you you
go for it or you're
you're gonna you know you're gonna be
laying at the bottom of the ramp
and you did it so here he missed he
didn't make it
yeah he missed it yeah but he got
so these these are all other celebrity
skateboarders you're seeing where is
this in california is that
is that like the the mecca of
skateboarding borders i think yeah i
think they're in san diego
which is the quote mecca of
skateboarding so you see here they're
sort of doing something like it looks
like uh
almost magic on the guy they're they're
okay they're trying to give them the
holy spirit or something but
most of them are not religious so i
don't really understand that right so
i think it's more of a showmanship type
of thing that they're doing right now
so yeah that's the interesting part like
they're trying to do some wudu on him or
something right they're doing voodoo
yeah look look yeah you see it look
well yeah he's just you know it takes a
lot out of you when you're slamming and
and
you know you're trying this it's it's a
lot of effort so i i do understand that
he's
so he got it now i i think he tries it
right here and he ends up getting it
yeah and then
they go wild and there's a little speech
and yeah there it is after the aftermath
so he's a big influence i mean
everybody's favorite skater he's the uh
you know the sort of the
unwritten sort of uh ambassador
president
so to speak of skateboarding right so
this is the part now right
where where he says thank you this is
the best day of my life
i swear to god
yeah it's funny it's funny i've seen
that sometime after it happened and then
you know i
i realized he said i i swear the god
right and i i've heard other skaters say
this on uh
did he did he say i swear to god no he
said i swear the god
which is is strange i haven't heard this
this wait hold up hold on
is that what he said let me back that up
hold on i swear to god
yeah i don't know if it's just like uh
like his accent it's hard to make
totally make out
it's where the i so go ahead so what do
you think what do you what is your
analysis
either way if he's saying uh you know
it's the best day of my life i
i swear to god i mean a lot of people
use this casually um
you know just to to sort of uh
emphasize their point right i swear to
god they're not religious but when you
ask them about it it's uh
they're not religious it's just even joe
rogan we see joe rogan do it
time and time again yeah or when they're
doing a uh
um a ufc fight oh my god he's knocked
out and
we know these guys are sort of
proclaimed atheists or
deists or something like this right so i
thought it was strange
and uh so i did a little back-checking
and found out you know
i don't know you know what about tony's
religion what are people saying about
them and
and this and that so what it came down
to was it seemed like he was an atheist
in most of the places it's mentioning
he's an atheist and i do recall
prior to you know it may be buried on
the internet somewhere but a uh
interview with him
mentioning that he he believes in you
know
something that isn't religion right so
there's all these different methods that
people want to
say they don't believe in god and make
it sort of politically correct where
it doesn't really offend anyone which is
good when you're a big brand like
like tony right so you don't want to
offend anybody
but you you have because you grew up
skateboarding
you you know the industry you know the
people you know
what it's all about from the
skateboarding but also the lifestyle
that goes with it
so when you have a lot of youth coming
up and many parents they're just
oblivious to a lot of these things so we
want to get the inside scoop
of skateboarding and the lifestyle
so let's talk about that you mentioned
that the majority is it true
of skateboarders are atheists
oh would you say i would say the higher
up on the
totem pole you go that it would be this
would this mean
is this basically this is off your
experience of skateboarding for all
these years and being
around the the skateboarders and
yeah i mean in general it's sort of uh
it's a counter culture skateboarding is
a sub counter culture as they call it
right um
like like the kids who are skateboarders
i wouldn't say necessarily every kid
that's a skateboarder as an atheist but
um i would say the higher you go up the
totem pole of the industry you'll find
people become more distant from
from god or religion or anything like
that right
i'm not sure what the significance of
that ratio is
but uh yeah in general what you see is
more of a devil worshiping side of
the branding side of skateboarding right
so the higher ups are the ones who make
the decisions on
what graphics are going to be on the
board you know how are we going to dress
this season when they do their their
clothing lines
you know what what what symbolism is
going to be on the shirts this is all
drafted in
big cup distribution companies that have
an arts department and things like that
which is a very tight-knit family
of people around my age and your age who
grew up in the 80s and 90s
who ended up inheriting the whole
skateboarding industry right
or or being part of the absolute elite
part of the skateboard industry
so again out of san diego pretty much
everything
comes out of that area with regards to
skateboarding
yeah so now that's interesting because
in much of the the the logos and you'll
see
like the satanic looking
emblems in that but then and
have you seen people going down that
route of
because why that's the question why is
it all over uh the skull and bones and
these kind of emblems why are they in
the the uh
paraphernalia that they sell and their
logos why do you think that is
well i think because in the early times
of skateboarding it was surfers
and rejects basically these are these
are society's rejects and society's
rejects were attracted to a lifestyle of
sort of degeneracy sort of right so punk
rock and
alcohol and womenizing and everything
that goes along with that living dirty
uh you know eating dirty all of the
above so the skull and crossbones became
something
recognizable in the 80s which is sort of
uh synonymous with maybe
uh you know the heavy metal days as well
that sort of is
synonymous with that too with the
pentagram and you know metallica and
those types of bands so that
that sort of fuses with skateboarding so
punk and metal
it has sub genres within skateboarding
as well so you'll have this
hip hop class of skateboarder you'll
have a punk rock class an alternative
class so there's
all these different fused uh appeals
that you can brand to these different
sub genres as well right so
but yes if you walk into any skate shop
and you're you're
you're a parent and you know the
difference between something
of a lewd graphic and something that is
you know funny versus something which is
satanic right you can look up on the
wall and there'll be 60 different
skateboards and you'll see 10 of them
have some sort of skull
skull and crossbones or very openly
satanic stuff right which uh
maybe we could talk further about yeah
so if you mention um
so because i i really i don't believe
that anybody
is born an atheist uh or even
somebody who goes into this kind of
lifestyle you kind of just have to
because your conscience is there and
you're fit
your innate nature to want to worship
something so then you gotta kind of mask
that so people just
you know uh try to cover up that natural
belief
uh but then you bring in satan into this
into the the branding and all that but
if then
you know i've talked and spoken to a lot
of people and this is what convinced
them that there is a god is that
you know if there's a devil if there is
and you see all this evil that's
happened in the world there has to be a
god a creator so it's just interesting
that they
that now even in what you would think is
innocent my child or my
you know is coming up with the
skateboarding parents and
we just people in general have to be
careful would you say
you know because okay it's one thing
you're skateboarding in the backyard but
now if you really get into
the group culture and the skateboarding
culture
it could be very dangerous would you say
i'd say
it depends like i said there's there's
there's bad apples everywhere yeah right
but i mean
if you have a good group of friends
which my son we go to the skate park
like almost every day it's actually
snowing up here in canada now so i think
to see
the skate season is over but we sort of
pick and choose the nice kids we find
the kids that have decent habits
and we we try to stick with them and the
ones that don't we try to give them a
little bit of a good influence we try to
pump them up a bit we know that they're
coming from
broken homes and strange environments
and that's what it comes down to with
with parents is you're sending your kid
to an environment whether it's a
baseball field
a hockey rink or a you know the mats in
the gym
uh the skate park you have to sort of
guide your kid before you send them in
there and know that like this
environment has certain
aspects and terrains that i have to
for i have to know myself as a parent
what's really going on in there
right yeah what kind of music is
associated with skateboarding
are these kids swearing every five
seconds how is this going to affect my
child these are questions
questions uh i see a lot of parents at
the skate park and i'm skating around
you know it gives me an excuse as a 40
year old guy to
run around right so they normally sit
there and they're just playing on their
phones right and i get to the point
where it's like you know
this isn't a a phone playing you should
be watching your kid
you should be paying attention to your
kids you should be showing your kid that
you
care about this hobby and you're not
just staring at your phone like a drone
right and it's not a good influence to
me in an active space
for people to be being
doing something like playing on the
phone with which is very uh it's harming
to be quite
be quite frank right it's not
progressive or creative it's very
uh it's lazy it's lacks so not
necessarily that
skateboarding is something that but now
if you get deeper into the culture
it can be it could be something that
could be dangerous
right so this is the sort of disclaimer
to parents is yeah
your kid is going to read certain
magazines or watch certain channels on
youtube okay okay so we're talking about
that's when you get into the literature
because they got their websites
literature and the
philosophy yolo you only live once yeah
exactly so i mean it's the sort of throw
your throw up your horns type of thing i
don't like to do the symbol with my hand
and i don't recommend anyone really
doing that symbol out of fun or
otherwise but
this is sort of the thing you're you're
throwing your body around you're a
skateboarder obviously
you know you have to look at what the
sport is and see it for what it is it's
people it's grown men throwing
themselves down
huge flights of stairs and you know
landing on solid concrete like even
football players
at least you have a little padding when
you're hitting the ground right on a
football
field it's a it takes a toll on you
you're gonna hit your head there's all
these other things and at the same time
it's a huge environment of an eclectic
group of of people
so you have to know your friends the
parents you should meet those friends
you should sit and talk with them you
should find
out even talk to the parents i talk to
the parents at the skatepark to see who
how is this kid being raised for example
and it gives me a chance to
talk to them about how why my kid is so
well behaved
or why why i'm here paying attention to
my kid all the time so
so diligently right um
so it gives people a chance and parents
especially during this whole uh pandemic
thing we
we should be going outside and meeting
each other this should never have this
should never stop to be quite honest
right
so i like to meet and have an excuse to
meet other parents and it seems
as a culture as a as humanity nowadays
where
we're divided to the point where you
know i used to help old ladies as a
child just cross the road and that type
of mentality saying please and thank you
in basic manners is seemingly
disappearing and and that comes from in
the home
so we even try to instill some of those
pleas and thank yous to kids at skate
park
just to give them it's their habit that
they're swearing in their route and
things like that so you have to show
them another habit a habitual way of
life
that will clean them of that because
they have to you have to practice these
good
deeds and these good manners to to
actually have them
right it just it's not going to come if
your home is broken and your mom and dad
are swearing and i know that's a lot of
the cases for
these kids who are running to
skateboarding because it's you can
be a very aggressive person like i was
as a child a hyperactive kid an adhd
affected kid or even people with
disabilities are skateboarding with with
no legs
some of these people so it's very open
to anybody
but we we still have to be uh uh
teachers
uh even our k our children are teachers
for other kids when we send our kids to
public school
and you're expecting your kid to come
home shiny like a diamond
you don't know you've send your kid to a
environment where there's 99 percent of
bad manners
how do you expect what how what logic
are we using to say if we send our kid
to the garbage dump
that he's not going to come home
smelling like garbage right this is uh
this is crazy this is illogical this we
have to we are pretending
as muslims that this is safe to send our
kids to certain environments
and they're not going to come back
affected even on the computer
even on those certain channels that we
watch it's going to affect us because
it's going to become a habit that we're
used to and then we're just going to
emulate that either good or bad behavior
right so inshallah this is every day is
a
test for the believer you're going to
run into people and you should take
advantage of those tests
no matter how small it is to get a
little bit of goodness across to someone
even if you're not i'm not perfect i'm
not saying i'm perfect at all i have a
lot of shortcomings but
when we look at the x-ray vision into
other people's homes
trust me they have much more problems
than we even if we're the worst muslims
we have islam we can say one ayah and
help someone
and we can even just talk to them about
the oneness of the creator
right this is very powerful to some
people because they never hear it all
day long
wow so you said some words you said
alhamdulillah which means all praise to
the creator that was on earth in arabic
allah you said islam
so you actually for people who are
tuning in and wondering is he muslim
you just gave it away
when did you accept islam and then for
those who are
skateboarding fanatics and now you go to
the competitions and
if you're a muslim now you're on that
pure oneness that pure monotheism
and then you've got somebody doing this
voodoo stuff you know you see how that
creeps in the [ __ ] you know the
the paganism the polytheism you know
these kind of things
that you know we have to really be due
diligent even in skateboarding you see
you see when they were coming around and
doing this good luck
charm all this stuff this this is
something that islam came to uh uh
eradicate and educate us
against that so uh when did you accept
islam and then
is was this in this video that we saw
was did you see other forms of shittake
or any uh
other things like this that were that
parents should be aware of
or just muslims in general who are
skateboarding
uh for the muslims out there i know uh
dubai did some big stuff they did in x
games in dubai quite some time ago right
so
uh it's been established there there's
actually a uh
charity in afghanistan which to me i
have other opinions but i'll
let you know there's it's called
skadastan where they're
they've set up a skate parks in in
different places in kabul
in uh in the big cities in afghanistan
and they're allowing kids a mode of
expression
in these you know places which are
war-torn
to for the children to express
themselves and to be together with other
children right so it
it has a good point and to me it has a
different point because there's a lot of
girls who are in there and there's a lot
of mixing going on in there and that's a
different topic but i mean
overall uh helping kids in any method
and
i believe skateboarding is a good mode
of expression but you still the
disclaimer is still there
of be careful of the subcultures that
are
involved in in skateboarding there's sub
subcultures and there's
open satanic satan practices on one side
which is obvious is very obvious so just
be aware of that and don't get sucked
into that find your friends who are the
good ones
you guys like like the muslim has an
unfair advantage actually in
skateboarding right
they have the muslim has an unfair
advantage in all sports to be quite
honest
as we see with habib as we see with
other great champions who are muslims
what's what's their advantage one they
have the power of the creator of this on
their side
two they don't do any of these weekend
warrior type of
of antics after they win you know after
they win they have a hamburger they
don't go to the nightclub and
you know tear it down all night right
this is not
something we want to do so if we want to
be olympic level skateboarders
or olympic level uh
jujitsu practitioners or etc etc
just not drinking just not playing that
entertainment game
filling that void of you know what's
what am i going to do on the weekend
with
why don't you push a little further than
your competitor
and keep working out that weekend or
practice more that weekend and trust me
you'll see in a year
two years three years the people you
were growing up with who
sort of subscribe to that other type of
life they're going to be falling behind
there's no way you can say they're not
right because
it takes a toll if you're an athlete you
have to behave like an athlete if you're
a professional football player versus a
professional football player who's an
alcoholic on the weekend or a
you know addicted to certain vices
then you're not going to turn out as
well as the muslims all the muslims out
there
stay on the deen and you can become
greater than anyone because
you don't have all those things pulling
you down and wasting your time
truly i mean we all watch a show now and
again and watch a movie
and this and that and burn off some
steam but i mean
academically we can move ahead faster
and this is all
revolves around the dean and how easy
the dean actually is
and we over complicate it right and
we're drawn to those
those things when you're a college
student university student
someone in a workplace you're in an
environment you have to be aware of
what's around you right you have to put
up a force field
of dean and be aware of what's going to
be in that environment even college and
university we know a lot of people go
and they come back and it's
uh there's a new person at your door
right after three years
he's been programmed he's been
normalized he's been
he's been taken by shaytan really right
he's been taken by the devil
and temptation has overwhelmed him and
he didn't have sort of the support
mechanisms that or or he didn't have the
the map of the terrain which i'm giving
people now i
if i go on a vacation somewhere if i go
to chicago
i've never been to chicago i'm gonna
call eddie and say eddie give me a map
of this place so i can navigate around
here without
going anywhere i shouldn't go right so
this is the same with life if we've had
certain experiences we have to tell
people
i have to give my brother something that
i would want for myself
and i would want that sort of cheat
sheet to
whatever endeavor i was participating in
that i wouldn't fall into any traps on
the way
right so these are uh sort of little
little analogies hopefully some people
are catching on to but they're very
useful
and and there's a few analogies i use in
life and one is
when you see a group of a lot of people
doing something in one time
right and before you jump in the circle
of all those people
critically think for a second say what's
going on there what's the benefit what's
the harm
you know let's take for example you see
a circle of
a thousand people smoking cigarettes
right and you're an outsider and you're
like hey um
kind of looks normal to me right um one
of those thousand people must have
looked into
what they're doing right one of those
thousand people must
you know so i should go join them that's
how most people are behave nowadays they
just
they hear something so many times and
they just jump in there right
yeah you have to do your research no
matter what it is if you're going to
this college
do some research on the college do some
research on the environment around there
how many nightclubs are there
you know how many murders happen there
or something you know so
you have to take take heed you know what
i mean you have to be alert nowadays
you can't just walk around with your
head staring at the ground
and think you're going to go anywhere
right you have to be alert of the hockey
players if you're going to get into
hockey jiu jitsu
are they playing music all day long in
in the dojo right like is
this affects you right my kid was in jiu
jitsu recently
i had to pull him out because the
teacher was
very experienced and very good i liked
him um
played the same tape on loop every time
and it was it was hypnotizing even me
right yeah right so i i know they put it
on to keep the kids concentrated or
there's some
some wisdom behind it but i mean i
couldn't handle it myself
so i had to get out of there yeah sad
right rich
solid points man solid advice
before we um conclude tell us would you
if you had the opportunity to talk with
someone again like tony hawk
who's now up there in age he can see
that is he also be coming now for the
new generation
that are coming up like people now are
forgetting who michael jack i mean
michael jordan who
like you start to get uh new the new
generation comes in and now you got the
what you said he was doing the 900 you
got kids now doing the 14
what 40. so he's gotten up in age and
i'm sure he's seen people around him
that have died you know
now to get him to think you know purpose
of life why am i here what am i living
for you know where am i going when i die
what kind of things uh would he because
you obviously got turned out to islam
submission to the creator not the
creation you know and this is
your way of thinking now is formulated
by
uh this way of life so if you would get
a chance to talk to tony
hawk uh what would you like to what
would you tell them
i would say obviously we're all getting
old in age right and we don't know when
when the time is going to come whether
it's an accident from extreme sports or
whether it's
walking down the street and you know
it's your time and your heart goes
and at this time currently in
skateboarding some of the legends
a lot of the legends and filmers and
some of the you know the guys who work
in the behind the scenes of
skateboarding yeah they're dying
tony's going to funerals probably every
year he's going to bury one of his
friends
and i don't know what the the
proceedings are like
um but when you you know we're told as
muslims
you know reflect on the afterlife and if
you
to humble yourself go and visit the
grave go and visit the grave and look at
the ground and and contemplate you're
going to be in there
right one way or the other you're going
to be in there and another thing from
someone who doesn't have a lot of
islamic education or hasn't had time to
read quran or hadith or even the bible
or any of these
these books i would say like tony
he should maybe he
maybe he's averse to reading those those
things right
so the fact is before you were alive
right
to tony hawk before you were here on
this planet you weren't here
right and then you don't remember being
a baby but now you're grown up
right so before you were you were
nothing
right then you became something that you
had consciousness
then you're going to die and you're
going to be nothing again
then you're going to be revived again
and you're going to have consciousness
so to say that's impossible
would be to say you denied your own
existence now right because you were
nothing before
we can agree on that we we weren't a
thought
before we were born right then we became
the baby that
needed to be helped et cetera then
you're going to become old and you're
going to need to be helped
whether you're a billionaire a
multi-millionaire
someone may be you know changing your
diapers in a few years right and it's
time to think before
that time comes and to reflect on the
grave you're burying people every day
remember you are nothing so a lot of
people say man when we die we're just
going to become it's blackness
you know the dream is over but it's it's
another analogy is when you when you're
dreaming
and you wake up and you felt like that
was real right it's the same thing when
you die you're going to just go to sleep
into a dream state you're going to wake
up in the grave
and depending on how you were as a human
being here
on earth and the religion you follow and
the truth that you followed and the
creator that you followed
then you will be judged accordingly even
in the grave so
i wish him the best i can't say he's not
an intellectual man
so the intellectual side is there and it
just comes down to
make an effort know the people who are
around you know
know that one third of this entire
planet is muslim
and and you do business in muslim
countries for sure right your products
are in muslim countries
like we know sex cells we know this
skull and crossbones cells and stuff
and it's just sort of a trend maybe in
skateboarding maybe they don't even
contemplate this
right so my message to tony is
get to know a muslim go into a masjid
where wear a mask no one's going to
recognize you nobody wants to take your
picture in the masjid and expose you
that you're coming to
you know uh learn about islam or
something right it's like
do your due diligence on the side do a
little secret project
do what you can do but but learn
learning is good
learning about the afterlife is good and
the key conditions of being a muslim
are two simple things you believe in one
god
right you believe in one creator you
believe that that creator that created
the sun and the moon and the universe
and the stars that we see at night was
not a man
right very simple it's some superhuman
being that you can't even fathom
and that one day you're going to be in
the afterlife these are two
simple conditions i know there's more
conditions to being muslim but
for someone who want to know like tony
to believe in the creator
and to believe that after you die you
will be resurrected and judged
is something to start on right we have
to start there
beautiful thank you and this is coming
from a
veteran of the skate boarding sport uh
skateboarding for almost uh
over 30 years now 30 years plus nowadays
30 years plus
so we get we're getting a message to
tony hawk i want to thank you for
sharing that with us giving some great
points and things for people to reflect
and ponder over
thank you so much next time we're going
to have to get you back to get your ac
your actual story
inshallah inshallah yeah any time eddie
anytime i know you're a busy man
everyone's busy
but uh i would like that inshahallah
there's a lot of points i would like to
make to some
newcomers coming to islam and and the
transition and the things that you go
through and
yeah um it's always a good boost
sometimes for other brothers to uh to
hear something from a revert right um
perhaps from my experience and my son
also wanted to uh tell you guys ayato
kirsi
but uh he's in the other room so maybe
next time we can meet my son as well
sounds good inshallah thank you zane
very nice talking with you
too and if you like this episode of the
show like this video share this video
far and wide and support us on our
patreon page so we can continue this
work
thank you for tuning in peace be with
you assalamu alaikum
subscribe right now